hello everyone and welcome to the most
requested game from round nine of this
year's Tata steel Chess Masters it is
param maulu versus Max feram and both of
them really want to win this game I mean
you want to win every game but um yeah
maulu not having the best tournament
it's already uh round nine and he is
without a single Victory and he did lose
three games in a row that's incredible
for a for a player of his caliber he I
mean someone who almost qualified for
the F candidates tournament uh it's not
a crime to lose to Al a noback and we
three games in a row as they are also
amazing players but it's very unlikely
for someone of of param strength but
okay it did happen he had a bad start uh
he would very much like to bounce back
and Max having a a very very decent
tournament with a win against param in
this round he will catch up to the
leaders he will be half a point behind
the current leaders of the event so
let's check it out and see why this is
the most requested game of the round
param with the white pieces opens with
Pawn to D4 uh Pawn to D5 we have Pawn to
C4 Pawn to E6 and now Knight to C3 uh
the The Queen's gamb decline is on the
board and now Pawn to C5 the tarash
defends as we've had already quite a few
times in this event uh C captures on D5
and now C captures on D4 uh capturing on
D5 is the main line in some of the games
that we've shown we've had also the E3
line but this is the main stuff we have
Queen captures on D4 uh Knight to C6 now
attacking the queen of course you cannot
capture as the queen on D4 would hang we
have Queen back to D1 and now e captures
on D5 we have Queen captures on D5 and
okay this is a well exp explored
territory the Shara Gambit and black has
tried many things here like Bishop to D7
Bishop to E6 Queen to uh E7 but not the
move that MOX played here he played
Queen to C7 and it is now already as of
move seven that we have a completely new
game so let's see how you deal with this
the the Queens are obviously staying on
the board uh it's time to develop Knight
to F3 we have Knight to F6 Queen back to
D3 as it's attacked by the Knight we
have Bishop to E6 preparing to bring the
Rook into the game uh and now Pawn to E3
also you could consider Bishop to G5
before closing the structure otherwise
your your Bishop will be stuck on C1 H
but param goes for Pawn to E3 first we
have Pawn to A6 stopping any Knight B5
ideas and now Knight to G5 putting
pressure on that Bishop we have Knight
to B4 attacking the queen and now Queen
back to B1 this is the only good Square
for the queen otherwise Rook to d8 could
be very very uh difficult to handle uh
Bishop to C4 now offering a trade of
Bishops or play threatening to play
Bishop captures and C1 which would um uh
prevent white from castling and now uh
you have to play Pawn to A3 here you
could play some other moves like Knight
to F3 Bishop to D2 but point a point A3
is the absolute best he was not played
in the game I just want to show you why
point is is that after Bishop captures
and Rook captures okay the Knight has to
go back you play Knight C6 and now Queen
C2 uh you will play Bishop to D2 Castle
Queen side and the game continues
however in the game Parham played Knight
G to E4 and now look at this queen side
Castles by Max we have Knight captures
on F6 G captures Bishop captures Queen
captures uh and now just Queen to E4
offering a queen trade completely
disregarding Knight to C2 check that
will win the Rook on A1 so what what did
param had in mind here well okay Queen
captures on e4 makes sense Knight
captures and now First Pawn to F5
getting the Knight to less um enjoyable
Square Knight to G3 and now Knight to C2
with check just winning The Rook on A1
so what is this why am I even showing
you this game well okay let's see King
E2 Knight captures on A1 H and now of
course Bishop to D2 the Knight cannot
Escape Rook captures an A1 will happen
even if the Knight comes to C2 uh Rook
to C1 will uh secure that Knight so you
will win it so here Bishop to G7 going
after the B2 Pawn Rook captures on A1
and now Pawn to F4 getting rid of the
doubled F Pawn uh to mess up White's
Pawn structure but param not interested
he goes Knight to F5 attacking the
bishop Bishop captures on B2 and The
Rook to B1 and okay I mean it's a it's a
nice position for for a Blitzer bullet
but it's hard to imagine that you would
willingly go into this in a classical
game okay Bishop back to A3 we have e
captures on F4 and now Rook H to E8 with
check Bishop to E3 and now Bishop back
to f8 and you have this um position here
or uh just before Bishop to f8 it would
be much much better to go Rook E4 Rook
to B4 and then either trade Rooks or get
the Rook to B2 this would be very very
strong for Max H but instead he went the
bishop back to f8 and now Pawn to G4
okay param starts pushing his pawns on
the king Side Pawn to B5 uh we have King
F3 now comes Rook to D3 just nicely
activating the Rooks uh Knight to G3 and
now Rook to A3 going after the A2 Pawn
so of course uh you might defend it but
also Knight to E4 is a is an idea
because after Rook captures on A2 now
the Knight comes to F6 and attacks the
rook and the H7 pawn and once the H7
Pawn is eliminated then the other the
other H Pawn just marches forward so
what can you do here uh best for black
would be something like Rook to d8 or
Rook to E7 uh let's say we go Rook d8
Knight captures on H7 and now Bishop to
G7 uh Pawn to F5 preparing to trap the
bishop with Pawn to F6 not trap it but
uh you know limit its Mobility but okay
you can play Bishop D4 offer a trade of
Bishops and after something like Rook C1
check King to B7 you will go Knight G5
and it's a you know still better for
black black is definitely better black
is up material but I mean there will
always be the problem of the past age
Pawn so max does doesn't like this uh
and instead he goes for Rook captures on
E3 he gives up the exchange to get rid
of uh any any tricky moves F captures
and now Rook captures on H2 so you don't
have to worry about losing the H7 pawn
and now the Knight comes to D5 okay uh
what what is the plan here we have King
to B7 helping out with the defense of
those pawns and the situation on the
clock is 24 minutes for param and two
minutes only or maybe two and a half
minutes for for MOX here uh Rook to D1
trying to get the Rook into the game now
comes Bishop to D6 stopping that and
pawn to E4 just preparing Pawn to E5
Rook H3 check King to E2 and now Pawn to
H6 we have Pawn to E5 and Bishop to B8
still keeping an eye on that C7 Square
uh and now comes Rook to D1 uh so uh 10
minutes were spent on playing this uh
Rook to D1 move and it's not the the
absolute best way for param to play this
as now comes Pawn to A5 we have Rook
back to A1 Pawn to A4 now uh we have
Rook to B1 putting pressure on the B5
Pawn now King to C6 defending and
attacking the Knight on D5 Knight to B4
with check we have King to B6 both of
them now have reached move 40 so
additional time has been granted King to
D2 and now Rook to H4 just going after
these points and again it seems like
white is just uh prolonging the
inevitable I mean yeah it's uh it's it's
a better position for black uh okay now
you're Mater realistically you're only
up a pawn but uh still uh those are two
connected pass pawns on the queen side
you will probably pick off some pawns on
the king side uh it is winning for black
so Knight to D5 with check King to A5
and now you should play Knight back to
B4 just stop Black's counterplay on the
queen side but here uh Rook to C1 was
played and now uh look at this Rook to
H2 with check King to D3 and now Pawn to
A3 uh how are you how are you stopping
this Pawn from being queened uh Rook to
C8 is played going after the bishop here
now Bishop to A7 we have Rook to C7
attacking the bishop uh Rook to H3 with
check King E4 and now Bishop back to F2
while still guarding the A7 Square so
okay Rook captures an F7 uh creating a
pass Pawn for param as well and now
Bishop back to C5 uh we have Rook to C7
going after the bishop uh and now this
is um not the not the cleanest way to do
it as of course Pawn to A2 is coming and
if you capture the bishop then the pawn
just promotes into a queen but it's not
a problem Rook to C8 you don't care
about that pawn becoming a queen because
you'll just deliver a check and pick up
the queen on A1 so King A4 it's time to
have King to B3 ready if a check occurs
Pawn to E6 Now by param going after a
queen himself and now uh the correct way
to do it is Bishop to A3 you have to cut
off The Rook from uh uh guarding the A1
square and now there's really nothing
for white to do white just resigns here
you could play something like Rook to C3
to win The Rook but of course you don't
care you just bring a Queen into the
game Rook captures and you will have a
queen against The Rook of course
completely winning uh okay it's still
it's still a past uh E Pawn and a past F
Pawn but it is winning for black however
in the game Rook to A3 was played by Max
seems like it does the exact same thing
but it doesn't look at this Rook
captures on C5 and now what's the idea
well the idea is if you play A1 queen as
was played in the game now comes Pawn to
E7 and how do you stop that pawn well uh
there is a way I'm going to show you the
way uh or should I show you the way H uh
yeah I'm going to show you the way uh
the way is Queen to B1 check and only
after the king moves to E5 you will play
Queen to G6 to guard this queening
square and after Rook to C8 preparing to
to bring the queen into the game you
will give a check King to D6 and now
Queen to G6 and this will force a
repetition so this is how you get a draw
here uh or if King to D7 uh it's
actually winning for black Rook to D3
you don't mind white getting a queen
because you'll capture the Knight with
check and after King to C7 Rook C5 check
King to B7 you will capture the queen
captures and now play uh Pawn to B4 uh
and the the position is um objectively
completely winning for black the The
Rook will not be able to stop it's
merely a matter of playing two moves
with the King and advancing that pawn to
Victory while this Rook uh keeps an eye
on these pawns however in the game Queen
to h8 was played which seems like it
does the exact same thing it guards the
queening square if you know some somehow
you prepare the advancement of the pawn
queen will start giving checks uh but
there is a huge problem here as now
there is one beautiful winning move for
param feel free to pause the video and
win the first game for param while I
give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
all the way to C8 that's the move and
congratulations to everyone who found it
the idea is now if you capture The Rook
of course you see what's happening Queen
captures on C8 Knight B6 check uh wins
the queen and then you will just promote
this um uh Pawn into into a queen even
if you prepare with Rook to A1 to stop
it with um uh with Rook D1 the the pawn
is defended you just push the second
Pawn I mean you don't really care
everything is winning here for white so
instead after Rook to C8 Queen to H7
check was played giving a check but now
Pawn to F5 uh and Rook to G3 there's
just no way to pile up on that white
king we have E8 Queen H now comes Rook
captures on G4 with check and here King
T5 was played and he was in this
position un move 57 that Max vadam res
designed the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so really an
incredible game with with many ups and
downs just param just giving up the
exchange like he lost uh like he lost
any and all interest in this tournament
because he did lose three games in a row
and he didn't have a single win uh but
in the end he merges Victorious I mean
he's just a spectacular player he's a
beast uh you know whenever he plays I
mean every game that you've seen that he
lost uh he played brilliantly is just
that his opponents didn't really care so
here you resign because after Queen to
G7 check there just aren't any checks
anymore King to D6 and that's it you
have to play something let's say Rook
Queen B7 uh now it's just time to
Checkmate the black king Rook A8 check
King to B3 or something Queen to E3
check King B2 you're going to deliver
Queen to C3 check the Knight helps out
with that King B1 and now Rook to A1
will be Checkmate so really tough loss
for Max vadam he was really hoping to
win this one and join the leaders or
rather Advance it uh to half a point
behind the leaders but it will not
happen on this round but still four more
runs to go in the tournament uh many
chances for for everyone and now that
param won his first game who knows maybe
now Parham goes on a rampage we'll see
what happens uh so that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh uh I definitely
agree it was the absolute best game of
the round so hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Len Herbert Yun young and
Anonymous person ulim and Christopher
and rud Beret for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your
day